what's happening there reject nation we
are about to watch the final episode for
all of us are dead this show is now dead
at the real rejects
that's stupid really good job leave the
like if you can that would be great
full-length watch alongs for this or
over at our patreon become a superject
today thanks for everything
boys and prepper you guys are doing a
good job
i really hated that joke
let's do this
there's a theme
oh eerie
foreign
[Music]
yeah as the world burns there's probably
many fires around you just find one
gather round
i was about to say get some ribbons like
your boy
still helping out from beyond the grave
man he really thought way ahead
oh what
[ __ ] zombies
deal
oh
no
no
running anymore
the tree saw
[Music]
where are the damn soldiers
oh come on buddy come on buddy
no no
put cones on all their heads
yeah buddy
that's right my dude
hmm
i gotta get away from him at least come
on let him be a hamby let someone else
be a hamby
oh
wow
oh
buddy
stop
[Music]
yeah i let her feed a little bit man
much dead bodies i mean he just turned
she could probably get a snacking
fight it
[Music]
no
if he dies because of this
oh no
is she gonna be feeding
yeah she had to man
what
oh
buddy
no
no
[Music]
oh poor thing
you guys are gonna get lost
just let her feed a little bit more yeah
and then she'll be fine for like a day
or two
so stressed out
[Laughter]
oh man they're really split up now
all of us are separated
do not die to the living dead them all
right vince hit him in the head right
between the eyes
probably not they caught up with him i
didn't realize that
yes
all right they're finally safe
i was half hoping they just gunned them
all down
problems going all out
[Laughter]
the bleakest timeline let's go get him
that's another one for the fire
chief
growing
stronger who
she's just like her dad
damn no fear at all huh not anymore
she's going right back to houston high
camera come back
chung sun
man
oh namra
huh it's got to be you she's got the
fire
um
[Music]
it's so weird to not see them in their
school uniforms
um
[Laughter]
they're all going to get bit
just guinness
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's so far away i know
you're gonna be walking all night guys
wow there's a crater
i swear to god if green i'm still alive
he's gotta be
i'm counting on it this is gonna be an
angry severed head
come on
let it be here
come on she's got to be like right there
yes
you made it
yes
oh my god she looks totally normal wow
even her eye looks better
yeah she looks great man
[Music]
[Music]
i'm gonna clean up this one horse town
[Music]
anybody we know
anybody
familiar
you gotta
wow what the hell
[Music]
you got a surprise chong son back down
there
sort of god you better show us
[Laughter]
the chunks on
oh
[ __ ] god
no
no
oh how could you
no
is there a post credit scene i don't
look like it
dang damn it the opening of season two
is i'm recommending that going it was
nothing
uh everybody left actually
sorry guys didn't mean to get your hopes
up
anyway
you want to sit around fire
[Laughter]
oh buddy oh buddy what does that mean
i don't know man we'll go watch heavy
spoilers video now ending explained
it's a cliffhanger
damn
that's [ __ ] annoying
the writers were like
i don't know
is it gonna be weird if we bring
chung-sun back ah
what can we do i got it
we'll come up with the next
remember the sopranos just kind of cut
to black
let's do that
let's have them all do different
expressions one shocked one looks
horrified and the other looks
kind of happy
let's get that music going you know
ominous but not too ominous but
definitely not hopeful
we really gotta throw them off yeah
we gotta make sure that everyone's real
nice and confused we need options let
people come up with theories and
whichever is the best theory we go with
that's like that
smart that's a good way to market tests
without market testing
damn that's uh
that's frustrating
what about there's a bunch of
know-it-alls in our comment boxes right
now
it's definitely a bunch of clues it's
obviously this and this this guy yeah
all right in the end they had hope john
they had all of us have hope all of us
have hope in the end hope
hope persists
lives on and friendship even when you're
not around
why'd they um
why they might
shoot them
the soldiers yeah
hmm
you know
dude we're told too good question have a
major yelling in their ear yeah
yeah exactly do it now
uh yeah maybe they figured uh well we we
just bombed the city and we already got
you know uh bit non-symptomatic people
at the camp i just take our chances
they seem fine
and they definitely don't have i feel
like uh
i don't know it's my mind goes well it
would probably have been another scene
if they had nam ra with them where then
they would have been like onboarding
them and then they would have like
had a whole big situation where they're
like oh no we got another infected but
not
when they were killing everyone in the
streets that turned into uh
it was the first time most of them
killed right um yeah i think i don't
think most of them have killed yet at
this point yeah they've done a lot of
like holding off and stuff but that was
yeah it seemed striking the way it was
nope they are you know hacking at necks
and and puncturing heads and they all
changed by the end of this time the four
months were out there all especially
anja yeah everyone turned into a much
more like confident and hardened yes
like we just have to do it now it's like
we've spent so much time running and
hiding and now
now that we're just like in the final
sprint and we can't afford to stop yeah
you just got to do what you got to do
chunks song might be a lion chong son
might be alive i thought
i mean i don't know i don't know what
that would be teasing if not that
because yeah she looked shocked
and chongson's the only one we did not
see a body of true that yeah some
covered in ash but we also saw that he
was kind of protected
kind of he was still engulfed in the
flames i mean in that shot it looked
like we now got disintegrated so i don't
know
yeah yeah they golf chunks on too so
part of me is like i don't know you look
pretty dead but at the same time i'm
absolutely of the mind that they they
didn't show it so i mean they they end
that in a way that is um
[Music]
they they definitely ended a way like
they're setting up something
very different and very specific like a
new world they're going to live in
yeah
which would be cool i i've never thought
of that i feel like so much of you know
the what you think of with zombies is is
all of the events that have been
encapsulated in this season and most
zombie movies kind of end here so i
would be curious if they come back for a
season too and they really commit to
uh
yeah some kind of new world and not just
oh the virus made it to somewhere else
now you know
um it makes me curious because part of
me could see them leaving it there
and just letting it be like oh you don't
know who comes back but that allows you
this is a big show
yeah it's still top 10 in the u.s and
netflix yeah i know for sure it's a big
show it's coming back this is big
season two coming yeah yeah i know but
but if they wanted to i wouldn't be
dissatisfied uh just because i feel like
that is an instance of something where
it's left to your imagination there's a
pretty solid conjecture you could draw
but there are also you know other
possibilities
and it's
after all the bleakness a little bit
heartfelt you know who's your favorite
character in the end
god that's a tough one that's a tough
that's tough ooh that's tough no it's
easy no no no no no i'm wrong
no i'm ron's the most badass yeah namra
had the coolest trajectory yes
and i would say the archer girl
i really realized
both times when she was about to die in
the
this episode and last episode i was like
like really really worried mm-hmm
i loved her a lot yeah
she's not maybe the most fleshed out
character but i feel like she's got a
lot internally and also the girl
who's uh who's like super sick about
yeah yeah i feel like super admires uh
uh archery girl harvey hari and stud
muffin stud muffin and chong song and by
the end of cops
in seoul university
it's
he's my favorite character of the show
uh
hey respect to my boy daisu well he he
had good he good good songs you know he
was he was one of the you know he's he's
the guy you want on your team because
he'll make you feel all right uh despite
everything
no not it's it's kind of fun how they
like mess around with the pieces here
because nomura didn't strike me as being
like
would be the big cliffhanger or the lead
or something in the end
but ultimately
you mean like she goes from the most
reserved
to wanting connection
developing friends becoming more open
to then accepting who she is like they
all come to this like weird form of
acceptance and she has this like arc of
acceptance
and especially by who she is at the end
creating a whole new breed of species to
populate the planet and i mean even arcs
as as a leader as the president because
you know as time goes on she uh develops
more assertive influence and more you
know strategic uh prowess and yeah by
the end she's like leading the survivors
out here and i like the uh i like this
the strength and the struggles she had
to display in this episode in the first
half like her scenes where she was like
just struggling to not
like you see you get this one scene
where she's like [ __ ] up everyone on
the streets
and like destroying these zombies and
then you see how she's tempted to just
like sink her teeth into her friends as
well
the wedding's off
if anybody needs to be bit by a zombie
right now
never show her noise
you were loud
right you deserve to die
and come back and feast indefinitely
until someone blows your head off
yeah
and this was nice it wasn't like too
much of a flash forward we just went
forward like a couple of months see they
barely saw anything i know i don't know
what's going on with the world besides a
couple of anchors talking on the news
about hey when we get this all under
control we'll uh we'll figure it out not
that we needed to no no i thought it was
nice what we got
there was sort of this like fantasy way
it was captured in the end it's like
immaculate blue lighting
yeah like some kind of weird yeah i like
it like
it does take on this stream like quality
that i thought uh complimented it well
because after an experience like that
then
coming back to not like normal but like
you know living in a
quarantined camp like that must be a lot
more structured subdued you know
repetitive you know
like life returns to a certain you know
mundane
uh
welcome mundane quality and so i feel
like that was a nice tone to put against
that after everything it's pretty crazy
how just they are from fearful into
almost fearless
yeah i'd be terrified to still walk the
streets yeah none of them seem to have
trauma yes
that's one of the one things i've been
like
all right you guys might be [ __ ]
traumatized yeah the key is to having no
reliable adult figures
so you can't afford the time for trump
like they seem so like
but they got their [ __ ] together pretty
well but in the end you know they
outlasted
they're good now they don't need
anybody's help none of them seem
reclusive or
tormented you know
no they all just seemed you know
a bit depressed yeah you know but i i i
i love the little things i like i i love
the little uh like memorial the way that
they took time for that especially
outside the city at the tree where you
can tell like you know she has been and
probably a couple of the other kids have
been hanging stuff and leaving food yeah
like that was a really lovely little
human element
and it speaks to something that like you
know we do
here but i feel like it isn't quite as
ingrained as much that's sort of like
leaving things for those who have passed
in order to keep them alive
innocent a lot of i think culturally a
lot of people do i think why people do
it when a famous person dies
[Laughter]
oh my god you're correct
you are correct sir you that's good yeah
yeah yeah
which uh yeah in the white in the
american remake of all of us are dead
it's just gonna be brad pitt i love you
tom cruise i miss you kate blanchett i'm
so sorry
i think for other cultures there are
some stacks of flame and yawns that
we're gonna leave out in your memory
yeah that's that's just my whiteness
talking but but that was i'm not saying
all white people are all
yeah
oh man can you imagine this show
i want to see a korean zombie drama like
this but set in america so i can just
see what kind of you know allegorical
skewering they will give us
and arc quirks and peculiar how do we
make money off
how do we monetize this crisis as
quickly as possible how do we take as
little responsibility for it how do we
avoid like having to work together in
any way that helps anybody other than
our direct selves
well it's they go from uh this
school this world of a lot of like
isolation and reservation to bonding and
friendship
that's a really
it's like to i like how it's bookended
by that like it's so heavy on the
bullying in the first couple episodes
and then it ends on a note of hope and
friendship
you know that's crazy it's crazy stuff
but what happened to [ __ ] omg yeah
yeah i guess they just did i was about
to there's a lot left on the table yeah
i was like i guess
exterminated her the youtuber guy guy i
don't remember we didn't release
i don't they were in the bus yeah we
didn't see him die i don't think we saw
him does he influence her live on do i
did the character i see myself dude live
on i ordered one of those knit orange
hats and i'm gonna wear every reaction
from now on are they gonna
are they gonna try to get a school going
for them
nope are they gonna rebuild any of
haisan or is it just like exterminated
so their quarantine camp was positioned
right outside of there
that's how i would see that's the one
one of them what a weird thing you're
going to bomb this whole city and
position yourself over there yeah yeah
position your camp where i only got to
walk a couple miles to get this memorial
and then apparently i could still walk
to the school yeah
yeah i mean i i appreciated them being
like okay we're gonna in the last
episode being like we're gonna lure all
the zombies to some specific points so
that we can minimize the blasts and all
that stuff but it did seem like oh the
the quarantine camp really is like just
over here is it the same quarantine camp
uh it felt like it they even developed
they even left the cliffhanger with the
original two zombies
yeah yeah don't don't let them fall into
the wrong
shadowy government cigarette guy
i need them for my experiments we're
going to weaponize this and sell it from
united states
oh girly golly golly
yeah yeah there are some things left to
resolve i'm very fascinated to see how
this would continue
but uh it's a really crisp and well told
story for the most part and i liked too
even just like the little lyrical things
they would do like with the flashlight
like when he dropped that in the episode
where that actually happened i was like
oh here comes it's going to be like the
key thing that's going to get killed
somewhere
i like that they take time for little
poetic things like that like they find
the ribbons that paid off and she has
that one remnant of his to kind of
symbolize his struggle true yeah yeah
that's a good point
overall
beautiful stuff man some episode was
beaut this show
nothing but beauty beauty and bleak
beautiful bleak
beautiful bleakness
i want a guinom spinoff oh gee got her
wish though so burnt yes it did boy did
it
it's all ash now
oh and she didn't get to see it happen
though let's look up a couple of
theories while we're here
all right all right you know what now's
the time if we really faster on my phone
if i do this
all right all right don't worry guys all
of us are dead season two
theories
oh my god someone's gonna bite her
is that any second now she's gonna
attract him
all right can't be so loud chongsan is
still alive yeah we know yeah it's gotta
be
a little weird theory nombre's still
alive yeah well yes yes she's gonna die
off-screen
in the time it takes to produce season
two
uh the government is weaponizing the
virus gotta happen yes
it'll explore the zombie survival
i mean that would be interesting because
you know the hambies are going to have
to have their whole own
these are terrible theories yeah those
are like the most basic theories the
theories i want to know
is i want to know
um okay so the story was written with a
second season in mind okay so there's
gotta be a
a specific plan
that's exciting this is i mean this ends
at a place where i'm like i have to
imagine we'll see something kind of
newish for the zombie genre in the
second season
ma'am we'll get squid game or
all of us are dead for like for like
four more four years maybe years wow i
mean maybe less so for this because this
was planned with the season two in mind
but there were probably a lot of people
running around going dude
so popular we got so much to live up to
we gotta write this [ __ ] and not let
everyone down we gotta make money from
netflix
oh man all right guys well all of us are
dead complete what are your thoughts in
the finale what are your predictions who
did nomrod jump to hmm
hey the title's a lie all of us didn't
die
can't [ __ ] this show false advertising
all right see you guys soon